look I get it taking creaky old
applications and finding ways to
modernize them does not sound like the
most enthralling topic but you clicked
on this video and I'm so glad you did
because generative AI is revolutionizing
what is possible in the field of
application modernization and I'm going
to show you six ways in this table how
generative AI can bring old applications
into the modern world and the great
thing is it's generative AI rather than
you that does a bunch of the heavy
lifting so first let's define some terms
and we'll start with application
modernization now this is about bringing
Legacy applications up to speed to meet
current and future needs it's the
process of updating traditional
functionality to incorporate modern
Technologies modern capabilities and
modern architectures and look Legacy
applications have powered businesses for
decades they are generally resilient and
reliable no bad thing but as it evolves
integrating newer Technologies can
amplify their strengths and address
areas that might benefit from Modern
enhancements and in a study conducted by
the IBM Institute for business value 83
percent
of Executives said modernizing
applications and data is Central to
their organization's business strategies
so this is clearly a Hot Topic
another term I want to Define is
generative Ai and I rather suspect
you're quite familiar with this term
already it refers to a subset of
artificial intelligence where the system
is trained to generate new content now
this could be in the form of images and
text but it can also be the generation
of code and software functionalities
generative AI can produce output that
wasn't explicitly part of its training
data set which makes it a really
powerful tool
so I think it's pretty clear that
combining these two things is something
that is gaining interest and that same
ibv study reported that 89 of c-suite
execs agreed that generative AI in app
modernization projects will drive growth
by improving existing products and
services but how well let's take a look
at six examples it's not an exhaustive
list by any means but I hope you'll find
one or two things of interest to you
here and let me first caveat this by
saying that generative AI is not a Magic
Bullet and it's not infallible it's
always wise to double check its outputs
and make adjustments as needed all right
think the the lawyers should be happy so
let's get going and first up is code
generation
now if you've ever found yourself
spending hours coding basic modules or
structures over and over again it can
get a tad monotonous but by
understanding the requirements or
established patterns generative AI can
churn out code Snippets or even entire
modules for example let's say you're in
charge of building a data processing
system that involves connecting with a
multitude of API endpoints for different
functionalities generative AI can be
shown the pattern or structure of these
endpoints and in turn can Auto generate
the required code
all right that's Cogen now next have you
ever looked at an ancient piece of
software scratched your head and thought
what in the world does this do
I have in my first professional job I
was working with Cable billing code
written in RPG that was older than I was
enter
reverse
engineering
with its ability to analyze and
understand code structures and their
behaviors generative AI assists in
recreating or modernizing the existing
systems and applications even if the
original source code is lost so consider
a legacy CRM system perhaps it's built
like in the late 90s it's integral to a
company's operations but is now riddled
with inefficiencies the original
developers have moved on and the
documentation is let's just call it
sparse well generative AI can dive into
this system identify its various
operations and with a bit of assistance
generate a modern equivalent of the
software
another capability is in the area of
best practices
now let's face it keeping up with the
best way to do things can feel like
trying to hit a moving Target sometimes
so wouldn't it be great if as you code
somebody like Taps you on the shoulder
and provides recommendations well
generative AI can be that insightful
colleague by analyzing vast data sets
repositories and patterns generative AI
can proactively suggest coding or
architectural best practices
pretty handy now while we're on the
subject of making our lives easier let's
delve into the realm
of Auto healing systems
now a big challenge during application
application modernization is really
managing and reducing something called
technical debt so as applications evolve
earlier shortcuts and patches and
workarounds all remnants of historical
decisions made from back in the day can
become ticking time bombs leading to
unpredictable Behavior or system
vulnerabilities generative AI Auto
healing systems can actively monitor the
modernized application identifying and
rectifying Legacy inefficiencies or
issues that arise due to the older code
all right two more
next one
is context sensitive
context sensitive automation
and what do we mean by that well look
application modernization isn't just
about tweaking Legacy code we're
reshaping entire systems here so we're
talking about things like transitioning
to Cloud platforms and incorporating
devops and generative AI can bring
context sensitive automation where it
doesn't just blindly apply automations
it discerns the context like
understanding whether it's working
within a containerized environment or
interfacing with a decades-old database
this awareness ensures that the
automation it applies be it being code
migration or infrastructure setup or
user experience optimization is apt for
the situation
and then finally
we've got code
debugging
debugging that's a Time intensive
process at the best of times but
throwing interfacing old code with new
tech
things don't exactly get any easier
fortunately generative AI can analyze
code structures system interactions and
even user behaviors to quickly identify
bugs bottlenecks or potential areas of
improvement now there are a bunch more I
wanted to include but heck this table
has only got so many cells code
refactoring would have been another one
documentation generation I'd probably
had that on my list as well
now do keep in mind it's early days
these capabilities are still maturing
still if if nothing else I hope I've
piqued your interest in exploring how
generative AI can help as a
transformative force in the app
modernization space it's not just about
updating old software but Reinventing it
ensuring it's adaptable efficient and
ready for the future